- [Voiceover] In the last video,
I talked about how if
you're trying to maximize
or minimize a multi-variable function,
you can imagine it's graph.
In this case, this is just
a two-variable function
and we're looking at it's graph.
And you want to find the spots
where the tangent plane
is completely flat.
So one way to visualize this
is to imagine a flat plane
that just represents a constant Z value,
so a constant output
value for the function.
And if you kind of move it up and down,
you're looking for the spot
where it only barely intersects
with the graph at the top
before it's not intersecting
with it anymore, meaning
that there's no values
of the function that get above that point.
So you're looking just
for where it's tangent,
where you can find a
tangent plane that's flat.
But this will give you some other points,
like the little local minima here,
the bumps where the value of the function
at that point is higher than
all of the neighbor points.
You know, if you walk in any direction,
you're going downhill,
so that's another thing
you're gonna incidentally pick up
by looking for places where
this tangent plane is flat,
but there's also a really
interesting new possibility
that comes up in the context
of multi-variable functions.
And this is the idea of a saddle point.
So let me pull up another
graph here, this guy.
And the function that you're looking at,
here, I'll write it down, the function
that you're looking at is f(x,y)=x2-y2.
So now let's think about
what the tangent plane
at the origin of this
entire graph would be.
Now the tangent plane to this graph
at the origin is actually flat.
Here's what it looks like.
And to convince yourself of this,
let's go ahead and actually
compute the partial derivatives
of this function and evaluate
each one at the origin.
So the partial derivative,
with respect to X,
we look here and
X-squared is the only spot
where an X shows up, so it's 2X
and the other partial derivative.
The partial with respect to Y,
we take the derivative of
this negative Y-squared
and we ignore the X because it looks
like a constant as far as Y is concerned.
And we get negative 2Y.
Now, if we plug in the point, the origin,
in to any one of these, you know,
we plug in the point (X,Y)=(0,0),
then what do each of these go to?
Well the top one, X equals zero,
so this guy goes to zero
and similarly over here,
Y is zero, so this goes to zero.
So both partial derivatives are zero
and what that means is if you are standing
at the origin and you
move in any direction,
there's no slope to your movement.
And one way of seeing
this is to chop the graph.
So if we imagine chopping it with a plane
that represents a constant X-value
and we kind of chop off the graph there,
what you'll see, here, I'll
get rid of the tangent plane.
What you'll see is that the curve
where this intersects the graphs,
let me trace that out, the curve
where it intersects the graph
basically has a local
maximum at that origin point.
The tangent line of
the curve at that point
in the Y direction is flat
and it's because it looks
like a local maximum
from that perspective.
But now let's imagine chopping
it in a different direction.
So if instead, we have the full graph
and instead of chopping it
with a constant X value,
we chop it with a constant Y value,
then in that case, we look at the curve
and if we trace out the curve
where this constant Y
value intersects the graph.
Let's see what it would look like.
It's also kind of this parabolic shape.
Again, the tangent line is flat
because it looks like a
local minimum of that curve.
So because it's flat in one direction
and it's flat in the other direction,
the tangent plane of the graph
as a whole is indeed gonna be flat.
But notice this is neither a local maximum
nor a local minimum
because from one direction,
from one direction, it looked
like it was a local maximum.
Here, I'll get rid of that guy.
It looks like it's a local maximum
when you look on the curve there,
but from another direction,
if you chop it another way,
it looks like a local minimum.
And if we look at the equations,
this kind of makes sense
because if you're just thinking
about movements in the X direction,
the entire function looks like X- squared
plus some kind of constant.
So the graph of that would look
like an X-squared parabola shape
that has a local minimum,
but if you're thinking
of pure movements in the Y direction
and you're just focused on
that Y-squared component,
the graph that you get for
negative Y-squared is gonna look
like an upside down parabola.
Here, I'll draw that again.
It's gonna look like
an upside down parabola
and that's got a local maximum.
So it's kind of like the X
and Y directions disagree
over whether this point,
whether this point
where you have a flat tangent plane
should be a local maximum
or a local minimum.
And this is new to
multi-variable calculus,
this is something that doesn't come up
in single-variable calculus because
when you're looking at
the graph of a function,
you know, you're looking
at some kind of graph.
If the tangent line is zero, you know,
if the tangent line is
completely flat at some point,
either it's a local maximum
or it's local minimum.
It can't disagree because
there's only one input variable.
There's only one X as the
input variable for your graph.
But once we have two, it's
possible that they disagree.
And this kind of point has a special name
and the name is kind of after this graph
that you're looking at,
it's called a saddle point.
Saddle point.
And this is one of those rare times
where I actually kind
of like the terminology
that mathematicians have given something.
Because this looks like a saddle,
the sort of thing that you would put
on a horse's back before riding it.
So one thing that this means for us
as we're gonna try to figure out ways
to find the absolute maximum
or minimum of a function,
as we're trying to optimize a function
that might represent like
profits of your company
or a cost function in a
machine learning setting
or something like that,
is we're gonna have
to be able to recognize if
a point is a saddle point.
And if you're just looking
at the graph, that's fine.
You can recognize it visually,
but oftentimes if you're
just given the formula
of a function and it's some long thing.
Without looking at the graph,
how would you be able to tell,
just by doing certain
computations to the formula,
whether or not it's a saddle point?
And that comes down to something
called the second partial derivative test,
which I will talk about
in the next few videos.
See you then!